[Applause]
okay we're back and we're going to ask
the questions from the internet Salman
would you write The Satanic Verses today
fortunately I don't have to cuz already
wrote it no I think what they're
probably asking yeah I know what they
probably ask Eugene what do you stick
with it what do you think would
incentivize change in our approach to
the war on drugs well I think if we
found a way to remind the American
people what a huge amount of money this
is costing us that you make profits
simply by pulling back on this insane
waste of money we've spent a trillion
dollars in 40 years right and also that
they're probably less safe right because
the cops sure are going after drug stuff
and when cops have to spend all their
times breaking people for little petty
arrests right they lose their focus on
the real crimes that we should worry
about
exactly
Chris Matthews are you taking heat for
being willing to call a comment racist
sometimes before anyone else has raised
the issue no uh everybody I met who's
African American is come up to me about
six inches away from me and very
personally said thank you
it's a and I met I met some people in
Mozambique um it's a big one in Jamaica
it is an international reality and
everybody feels it on that side of the
racial divide and it's disgusting that
white people who to whom the dog-whistle
is aimed refused to acknowledge it it is
there it's been part of our politics we
thought it was going it's back and it's
being used to get votes okay and if
profit if profits are up for companies
shouldn't the results of their
prosperity would be more evident in the
salaries of Americans you would think so
but though as I said earlier the labor
share the pie is the lowest it's been in
40 years I think one of the reasons for
that is that companies aren't investing
in the u.s. they're investing abroad
that's why we need to get more
competitive at home yeah I mean what I
mean I mentioned trickle academics a
couple a couple of times in the show and
came up don't you think that worked only
once you know when Reagan brought the
rates down from 70 was it 70 percent to
28 of course that was gonna Goose the
whole thing but you kind of kind of shot
your load I mean to do it
it kinda can't do that every time now
that they you know we're at 36 I mean
really what would it change I would hope
the common ground would be not only to
look at just the tax but to look at the
other things the trillion dollars it
costs a small business to comply with
regulations for example government is
just too big too oppressive too complex
you start a little stand somewhere
you're going to lemonade stand your 11
year old girl and a guy comes and shuts
it down from the local city because you
don't have a permit this kind of stuff
has got to stop
and that's happened in a that's happened
in a lot of places you know I'm going to
push back I think that you can cut red
tape but I think if you talk to older
people in business I mean someone like
Warren Buffett when tax rates were far
higher growth was also higher or two I
just don't think that entrepreneurs are
going to leave because of tax rates and
red tape the corporate rate they are
leaving now as you point
the corporations are investing overseas
because the corporate rate is the
highest in the industrial world
Sweden is distinct that's what the
growth suite and why is it the growth
Sweden just cut their corporate rate to
22 percent ours is 35 in socialist
Sweden we should we should streamline
taxes we should get rid of loopholes
that people who should be paying more
taxes should be not taking advantage of
and I think that we also should lower
tax rate on earned income to go back
here 20 but the people that are working
really hard in this country not lazy
[ __ ] calling this comeback
lower taxes here and make people appear
close the loopholes lower the rates
that's exactly actually the communist
and and you know regulations are not
hindering the economy it was like our no
it's fundamental from you got to make
the u.s. more competitive that's that's
what it's so how do you do it well
you've got to invest you know and this
is happening at the local level cities
that come to game from Columbus Ohio
actually last week there you've got a
Democratic mayor who convention a
convinced a bunch of Republican city
fathers to do a tax hike first in 27
years the city is now booming they
invested in infrastructure and education
this is what we need to do with national
I mean it did work under Clinton you got
to admit that quit 93 tax hike under
Clinton which was only three percent on
the richest people you know it's not
exactly socialism to raise taxes three
percent on the top one percent you know
and this sub Romney thing Romney gives a
speech because it was a good speech down
there in the Tampa and he had a light in
the air about I'm just gonna help the
American family I'm not gonna stuff the
sea level from rising well you know he
did he told the joke again later on you
know that the trouble the premise of
that took their jokes are fine but the
premise of that joke was science is a
joke we you know New York City is now
retrofitting its subway to deal with the
higher sea levels that are coming
everybody knows it's happening we got 20
or so countries down in Southeast Asia
know they're gonna be underwater
underwater why is this a Ducati subway
though yeah that's underwater anyway no
the water will be in it that'll be a
problem
why comes over the city street it comes
over the sea levels rise the science
whoa that is bad I'm glad I live in Cali
wrong is you just have just the hope
he's gonna break off and fall of the
ocean you know they've been saying that
for years subsides oh no we got the nice
weather uh you know your San Diego be
come on we love it absolutely love it we
love LA nobody country going on Santa
Monica Boulevard we love ya know Beijing
used to identify yourself Amster go says
as a progressive Republican do you still
consider yourself such are you more
really identify with the Tea Party now I
tell you in a long time I've been going
through this stuff the environmental
stuff was is really important was really
important it's continued to be important
in California we've made remarkable
progress people don't give enough credit
needs of the nation always the nation in
this stuff now some of the nation follow
us and some of it gets a little
overboard I mean businesses are leaving
we got some problems of balance but I
live on the beach in San Diego and I
love it we have a height limit we have
some controls on stuff that it's not
gonna become Miami we're gonna have you
know a nice place for our kids and
grandkids and their grandkids that's the
kind of thing that I was committed to
and still AM
I mean it makes sense so are you a tea
party person or no no here's it I'll get
to that
you know the Tea Party think heard about
the beach I know I went a little bit
deeper you and the Tea Party I live on
the beach and I love
okay what do you think the Occupy Wall
Street movement has accomplished for the
middle class what has it failed to
accomplish nothing
vo wow that's a great question you know
the tents are gone but I think that
there's a real debate in this country
now about the fact that you can't have
an economy where 70% is cut out you know
and I think that you're going to start
to see change I think that banks are
going to be like well you know you can
talk 1 or 99 but basically there's a 70%
47 we got now I get now we got 17 middle
class you can't you should have this 70%
in the middle that are really crunched
you cannot have an economy working
without them spending right and I think
there's a real discussion about that now
I think that you're gonna start to see
banks regulated and broken up I think if
a bomb gets the second term you're gonna
really see people like Gary Gensler
who's maybe going to get the SEC post go
after the banks I think that you're
going to see people start to talk about
income based growth rather than trickle
down stock growth which isn't working ok
we got to go thank you very much
everybody we will take a week off
Real Time with Bill Maher ask bill and
its guests your questions right after
the show at HBO calm